le Paris-Nice partira ce week-end depuis
les Yvelines pour la 14e fois
consécutive ce dimanche 5 mars les
coureurs partiront de la verrière pour
une boucle de 169,4 km dans les Yvelines
une grande première pour la ville les
6000 habitants de la commune de 50 ans
en Yvelines pourront voir des sportifs
de haut niveau comme le vainqueur du
dernier Tour de France fionase Wingard
il y aura également étéage pogaccha
vainqueur de deux tours de France il y
aura des Français comme Romain Bardet ou
encore Arnaud démarre le départ sera
donné à 13h depuis la mairie au niveau
organisation un village sur Installer
dès le samedi 4 mars de 10 heures à 18h
au parc sportif Philippe Cousteau il y
aura des animations autour du cyclisme
le jour J la circulation sera très
perturbé dans la commune vous ne pourrez
pas circuler dans le centre de 6 heures
à 20h et il est vivement recommandé de
se garer du côté du parking de la
Commanderie les bus des équipes seront
installés devant le quartier du Bois de
l’étang le lendemain c'est la petite
commune de Bazainville qui accueillera
les sportifs ce sera là aussi une grande
première les sportifs partiront à 13h
direction à Fontainebleau